Now, let's talk through what possible values d and
c can have. You may have picked several of
these choices, but it is okay, you know, whatever
you picked, it's okay. Let's talk through these different choices,
to see what are possible given this set of
instructions and the fact that. Processing speed one and
speed two are executing, independently on two different processors
and, we have no way of knowing, what is going
on with the shared memory. Now the first possibility, is that, these two
instructions, assignment of, a B to D and C to A, they happen. In time
order, before any of these instructions executed.
That's possible, because if these shared memory
accesses happen before these guys, they're responsible
that both of these instructions are executed before
any of these instructions executed. In that case, what you would get into DNC
are the old values of a and b, namely zero. The second possibility is that
the both these instructions that is executed on P2 they're
executed after both the instructions on P1 have completed
execution. So in this case, both a has gotten new value, b has gotten a new
value, and so when we go here and make the assignments. Then both d and c are
going to have new values that are in b and
a respectively. And so, this is a possibility, right?
There is a possibility that both c and d have a value of one in them. Let's see
if the third possibility can happen. The third possibility
for it to happen, it is conceivable that we insert
these two instructions in the middle of this. Or
in other words Process P1 executed this instruction and, and
in time order, it so happens that these two
instructions got executed, and then this, this instruction got executed.
And therefore, once you get into d is the old value of b, that is
zero. And once you get into c is the old value of a. I'm sorry, the new value of
a. Because this instruction is executed. And therefore,
you get one into c. And that's why this
possibility is also, is also perfectly valid. Now,
let's look at this last choice that I have.
C gets zero and D gets one. Can this
happen? C getting a zero and d getting a one.
And the reason I ask you this question is because,
if you look at this piece of code and this
piece of code here. If d were to get
one, what that means is that, this assignment of b
gets b plus one has already happened on P1. That's
how the new value of b has gotten into d.
But yet, we're saying when this process completes,
c has a value of zero. What does
that mean? It means that the new value
of a hasn't come into the processor P2. How
can this happen? It can happen if messages go out of order. You have to remember
that, if you recall the picture of the
shared memory machine, you've got an interconnection network that
is connecting all these processors. And a write
that happens on this processor has to go
through the interconnection network and get to this
other processor. Now it is conceivable that if message
go out of order. It is possible that
when this process executes this statement. This new
value of b has arrived, the message that
contains a new value you b has arived and
there for this assignment gets a new value of,
of b, but when the process execute this statement. The
new value of a hasn't arrived yet and it
can happen if the messages go out of order and
in that case, you can end up with this
particular choice of c having a value of zero and
d having a value of one when this process
completes execution. Do you want it to happen? Now intuitively,
you would see that this is not something
you expect to happen. As a programmer, you don't
want surprises, right? And if you don't want surprises,
perhaps if it is a non-intuitive result, that's something
that should not be allowed by the model.
So, when we talk about memory consistency model, we're
saying what is the contract between the programmer and
system? And what we are seeing through this example
is that, this particular outcome is counter-intuitive and
therefore the model should not allow this particular outcome
to be possible in the execution. And this
is the reason why you have memory consistency model.